now let's talk a little bit I think that
the two most important issues the two
questions if I had just two questions
for any politician what are you going to
do about climate change and how are you
going to get money out of politics and
and we're gonna run into problems there
because I don't think you think climate
change is a real problem and I mean I'm
not alone I mean the most recent surgery
not only the most recent survey climate
scientist said about 57%
don't agree with the idea that 95
percent of the change in the climate is
where we go there was a survey down of
1,800 scientists and 57% said they don't
buy off on the idea that co2 is this is
the knob that's turning the client
there's hundreds every night out in
alignment I don't know what ass you're
pulling that or not that is how you know
that to the survey okay
it's 1,800 climate sign so that's number
one number two the 97% figure that's
thrown around the head of the UN IPC
said that number was pulled out of thin
air it was based on us on a survey of 77
sign not even 97 scientists responded to
that survey so let's just get let's talk
about facts and the fact is lots of
things cause climate change and then
let's talk about another another point
what are you going to do about it
and and how do we what it lets us what
are you going to do the answer is if you
look at what the president has proposed
an 80% reduction an 80% reduction
emissions and the consequence of that to
folks that I am running my campaign on
which are folks that are blue-collar
Americans who losing jobs to China and
losing jobs to Mexico because we are
twice as many jobs in solar as there are
in coal now you're living in the past
but I know that's your country in
Sylvania but it's not just coal its
manufacturing and it's the president's
about to propose a regulation on ozone
that according to the National
Association factor me has boy the
manufacturing economy in this country
well it's already sort of destroyed well
it is we have we have regulations that
story because because rich people send
jobs overseas or limit money say markets
overseas what is it let me get Spencer
to
in fact wait a sec because of because of
climate of other types of policies
including climate the Pope made a very
strong statement very strong statement
in support of my position on climate
change not yours and your position when
you heard that was hey let's leave the
science to the scientists okay first of
all you're not doing that but second of
all I am you're not because 97% of all
scientists believe is a bogus number
it's so not a bogus it's so yours is
mine as yours is mine
but what I want to ask you is I mean the
your I'm not a Catholic I'm not I'm not
I'm an atheist but I like the Pope
better than YouTube and I wouldn't go
wait a second you are you're saying the
Pope should stick to what he knows and I
find that also ridiculous because what I
always say so much of religion is
arrogance masquerading as humility
should he's the Vicar of Christ your God
shouldn't you have the humility to say
well if the Pope thinks climate change
is a problem
maybe I should he's not just another guy
if you were if you look at all the
things the Pope said which which I hope
you do he put it in the context of
trying to reach out to people who may
not agree with him on a whole lot of
other issues in order to try to open up
some doors and open up a conversation
which he's obviously done I mean Al
Gore's now saying he's can become a
Catholic because of this president I
mean because of this Pope I mean this is
he did he said you know I'm considering
becoming Catholic because of a Pope
Francis so I think he's trying to do
something to break down some barriers
because if you look at what are the
previous Pope's they've been pretty much
you know consistent on on on all these
things and what would be seen in the
world is conservative positions and he's
trying to reach out and bring some other
people into yeah so look at this I know
that a Pope every time he speaks he's
not infallible it's very rare once what
if he said this thing about climate
change that he said in the in the
context where it is infallible it what
if he did he wrote what if he did he
would not because it's the the Pope
speaks about infallible things Frank
call me yeah
you